deux millions de litres de lait ont été
jetés depuis le déclenchement d'une
grève générale illimitée dans une usine
d'agropur à granby la semaine dernière
ses 800 éléctro de l'est qui sont
transformées chaque jour c'est près de
10% de la production québécoise
on va en parler avec daniel gobeil
conjoint québec il est président des
producteurs de lait et producteurs
laitiers du québec montfort monsieur
gobeil bonsoir madame j'adore non pas
comment ça se fait là qu'on soit rendue
a jeté plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
litres de lait par jour en ce moment bah
c'est clair que c'est très regrettable
mais beaucoup de frustration et de et de
puissance pour nous nos membres cette
fin de semaine avec ce conflit travail
loki qui chez agropur la région de
granby depuis mercredi dernier oui les
producteurs de lait dont vous êtes le se
disent dévasté par ce gaspillage c'est
le fruit de leur travail qui finit aux
égouts si on veut ils sont pas
responsables ils subissent la greffe
chez agropur ce sont quoi les recours
disponibles pour les fermes laitières et
nous en sommes amassées je vous dirais
le contexte qui nous qui nous ait si con
un système collectif une mise en marché
collective fait toutes ces pertes au lok
sont sur les fermes en ce moment les
revenus le qui seront 2 0 dans leur jeu
pour un certain volume de lait seront là
cette nation de peyreleau va être
diminuée sur toutes les fermes le
collectivement mais c'est clair que pour
nous de cette fin de semaine et elle est
très difficile avec le congé trop beaux
jours également mais à court terme là
c'est clair qu'il faut trouver des des
plans de contingence efficace pour
éviter là que cette situation leur se
reproduit mais parce que c'est ce que ça
peut se chiffrer à combien la en valeurs
monétaires tout ce lait qui jeté en ce
moment bon je vous dirais qu'en ce
moment on a environ 85 dollars de
l'hectolitre pour le revenu le à la
ferme fax et des pertes lors qu'ils
peuvent aller à 2,3 millions de dollars
rapidement mais c'est clair que pour
nous l'eau en ce moment en ce début de
semaine tous les volumes ont trouvé là
une maison pour la transformation tous
les volumes de lait puis on envisage
quand même la court terme la dea
des jours meilleurs mais c'est clair que
pour les parties l'eau en cause le
syndicat des travailleurs et agropur ce
conflit-là l'on demande de trouver quand
même des des solutions là pour pour au
moins sauce offrir un service minimal de
transformation parce que l'enjeu
monsieur gobeil c'est que cette usine là
si on comprend bien chez agropur a
grande bcc névralgique pour l'industrie
ce une grosse usine c'est presque 10% du
volume produit au québec qui passent par
cette usine là est ce que les autres
installations sont en mesure vraiment de
traiter tout le lait qui devrait l'être
à grand baie oui bah c'est une très très
jeune une très très grande usine
effectivement on parle que d'une
capacité comme vous n'avez pas l'autre
de 800 mille dit oui certaines usines
d'eau du même transformateurs d'agropur
peuvent prendre le relais dans ce
conflit travail la vie d'autres grands
transformateurs la com com agropur comme
lactalis mais on retrace pas là quand
même là des camions de lait l'aude ainsi
à si court échéance de façon très rapide
fait que ça puisse faire au niveau des
producteurs de lait du canada on a des
systèmes là pour entreposer du beurre
pour entreposer du fromage pour donner
des outils là ces entreprises loki qui
voudraient nous aider en cette période
critique puis bien sûr là comme toujours
les banques alimentaires sont son son
sont toujours rappelés on est prêt à
donner notre produit c'est clair
qu'avant de gaspiller on veut donner
notre produit mais pour ça s'apprend la
contrepartie la des transformateurs qui
donne également la transformation et
toute la chaîne l'eau pour avoir
reproduit le sécuritaire produits
consommateurs ce qui est préoccupant
monsieur gobeil sais que c'est pas un
cas isolé il y en a à quelques reprises
dans une année on dit jusqu'à 300
millions de litres de lait qui sont
jetés chaque année au canada comprend
suffisamment de mesures pour éviter ce
gaspillage que ce soit parce que des
usines doivent cesser leurs opérations
pour de l'entretien ou des conflits
travail comme dans ce cas-ci sur les
volumes qui auront circuler aujourd'hui
beaucoup de sous pour aux huiles la
transformation on parle de sous-produits
d'écrémage on parle de ladebat bird de
l'est de lactosérum au niveau du lait
cru le je vous dirais que la dernière
épisode dramatique à la ferme date là de
la semaine suivant la ferme sur en temps
de pandémie pour du lait cru lorsqu'on
est capable de valoriser aucune
composante lot de tout notre lait que ça
soit le grand la protéine et lait
lactose c'est que c'est quelque chose
qui arrive quand même épisodiques mais
c'est clair que pour nous là c'est une
goutte de trop au goût de l'azoté c'est
une goutte de trop on veut travailler on
avait des résolutions dernière assemblée
générale de travailler sur des usines de
dernier recours mais bien sûr dont les
prix appliqués non plus dans la
transformation la dent le d'un jour
après jour mais ça va devoir demander de
l'aide des transformateurs et les
gouvernements pour que cette situation
ne se reproduise plus vous évoquez le
gouvernement le ministre de l'emploi
jean boulet aujourd'hui dit qu'on ne
veut pas tolérer un conflit de travail
qui se prolongent qui va forcer des
producteurs de lait à poursuivre ce
gaspillage est ce que vous comptez sur
une intervention de la part de québec
bah c'est clair que je pense que le
gouvernement ne veut pas rester immobile
on respecte les droits des travailleurs
de négocie on respecte également les
deux parties en cause mais pour 10 des
services alimentaires comme le nôtre
c'est inacceptable c'est inacceptable
puis des usines en a vu beaucoup de
consolidation également au niveau des
entreprises laitières au cours des
dernières années cette consolidation la
save y avait des responsabilités des
responsabilités de transformer des
volumes minimums pour limiter les pertes
sur les fermes au québec dans cette
période là où l'inflation l'oreille est
quand même là son apogée il sur les
coûts de production également parce que
pour le consommateur de voir ces
gaspillages un peu choquant surtout
quand on sait que les produits laitiers
qu'on achète en épicerie leurs prix sont
en forte progression est ce qu'il peut y
avoir un lien entre un conflit travail
comme celui là et d'éventuelles hausses
de prix pour le lait dans les mois à
venir dont nous donne un côté les les
coûts de production qui sont
annuellement par la commission
canadienne du lait de deux fois par
année cette année les six reviennent au
coût de production est allée lundi du
pied à la consommation fait le livre de
laidlaw aucun impact pour les
consommateurs mais je partage leur
frustration aujourd'hui le coproducteur
de jeter le travail de deux jours de
l'ale sur les fermes il n'y a pas un
producteur en fin de ce même qui était
qu'ils étaient fiers de ce nous y allons
clairement pas monsieur gobeil merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là merci à vous
cette journée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]